hi there and welcome to my channel
my name is tracy and i am a small scale
gardener
living on the prairies here in
saskatchewan canada
so if this is your first time joining me
on my channel i
enjoy making videos on cold climate
gardening
how to grow indoors during long cold
winters
along with sharing recipe ideas made
with ingredients grown in my garden or
locally sourced so in today's video i'm
going to show you how to make a cooling
herbal body and facial spray using fresh
herbs from my garden
so here on the prairies we're about
halfway through our growing season so i
have been busy collecting herbs
flowers weeds that i enjoy using
for cooking storing over the winter
and also to make a variety of different
natural body care products
so making hydrosols from your garden
plants is very easy to do
and it has a lot of different uses that
i will
go through with you and later on in this
video
so let's head into my kitchen and i will
show you how to steam distill your herbs
flowers and plants to make a hydro
okay so i'm just going to run you
through all the equipment you need to
set up your very own
steam distiller it should be easy to put
together with things that you have
around in your house
so first of all you just need a deep pot
and a lid that fits on securely you'll
be inverting the lid
this way a clear one is kind of nice
because then you can actually see
the steam distilling process happening
so
you need one of those you need a couple
dishes that are oven safe make sure that
they are
can withstand some heat so i'm going to
be using this
little ramekin as the base and
something that's got quite a wide
opening in here because this is going to
catch the steam from the lid
and that will sit on top so just make
sure it's something that
can sit securely so you'll be putting it
inside the pot like this
so like that and all your herbs and
water are going to go around
this area it's best if you're using
distilled water
and of course whichever herbs flowers
buds leaves whatever kind of
your favorite plant that you want to use
in this
process have those ready they can be
dried or they can be freshly picked
right out of the garden it doesn't
really matter
and the last thing you need to have is a
good supply of ice
so you know you don't want to have to go
out and buy bagged ice so
if you can if you have an ice maker of
your own
of course these ice packs work really
well if you have a good supply of them
and if you're planning a day or head or
so
make yourself some ice blocks or in
small containers
or just take some water bottles fill
them up
with water and freeze them overnight and
these will work good as well
okay so we're ready to get this set up
on the stove okay so once you have your
inverted container dish here in the pot
the next thing you want to do is add all
your herbs flowers
and whatever you are going to be
distilling
just sprinkle them around
for my recipe here today i'm working on
making a cooling
facial spray so i've picked from my
garden
some fresh rosemary lemon balm
peppermint eucalyptus
and i'm not able to grow lavender here
very successfully so i'm going to cheat
and add a little bit of
bottom lavender buds
so then next you're going to add your
distilled water and i just pour
enough in here to just
slightly cover the herbs about two or
three inches
to start with i'm going to be adding
more water
throughout the distilling process as it
slowly cooks away i usually top it up
two or three times
try to get the most i can out of all
these herbs
so there's about three inches of
distilled water in there
so you also want to make sure that
everything that you're using is
sterile because you don't want to have
any bacteria
ending up in your product after you've
created it
so i always give everything a good spray
with some rubbing alcohol
sometimes i use hydrosols in lotion
products that i make so you want to make
sure
that you're always keeping everything as
sterile as possible
so then you put your bowl on top here
that's going to catch all the steam
[Music]
and then put your lid on inverted
and to start with i turn on the heat at
a higher temperature to get the water
heated up
quicker and once it starts to bubble
turn it down to the lowest setting so
that you have it simmering very gently
and as it simmers away you'll start to
see the steam building up
on the lid and just to speed up that
condensation process that's when you add
your
ice and then i just let it
simmer away for half an hour to an hour
you don't have to stand and watch it
non-stop you can
go about your business around the
kitchen and the house and just check on
it just to make sure that the water
hasn't
all boiled away
you will also want to have some kind of
jar or container to store your hydrosol
in
after you've poured it off so make sure
you have something sterilized and ready
[Applause]
okay so as you can see here the water
is slowly steeping and steaming all
these plants carrying all that herbal
goodness
to the lid here where the uh the steam
is condensing because it's hitting this
cold surface
that we've created with the ice and then
from there it drips down
into the bowl and then you are left with
some beautiful hydrosol
so about every half hour so i like to
just remove the
ice and check my
collection of steam here
you want to be very careful because this
is very hot steam so you should be
wearing some kind of a
glove while you're doing this
so i like to pour a little bit off every
half hour or so
smells so amazing it's like having an
aromatherapy
thing running in your kitchen while
you're you know while you're doing this
it's just a wonderful smell to have and
then after
i've done this i usually check the water
level
just to max mount the amount of steam
distilled
hydrosol i can get out of this
batch here
so as i said the hydrosol i'm making
today is to use as a cooling body spray
or facial spray
what i love about hydrosols is that
their aromas are often very soft and
subtle
compared to using something with
essential oils
and the spray leaves your skin feeling
cool refreshed
and provides an uplifting aromatherapy
property so depending on what herbs
flowers weeds or even fruit or
vegetables you use
hydrosols or floral waters can be made
and used for many things
so with this process you can create a
room spray an anti-itch spray
surface cleaner bug spray bath tonic
facial toner hair rinse or
even a makeup remover so if you've made
any of these or have created a hydrosol
not mentioned here
please let me know in the comments or if
you'd like to see me make more hydrosols
in future videos
let me know in the comments as well
so ideally hydrosol should be stored in
the refrigerator to maximize their shelf
life but they can also be stored in
amber or
dark colored gloss bottles and kept in a
cool dark location
so i hope you enjoyed watching me make a
cooling body mist
using fresh plants from my garden and
that you will try making some of your
own hydrosols
i would appreciate if you give this
video a like leave a comment
and please subscribe and stay tuned for
the next video on my channel
thank you for watching